and he is a great athlete one of the
best receivers in the nfl from a talent
standpoint production standpoint we
haven't quite seen it for a variety of
reasons and in cleveland last year i i
look i i'm a firm believer that every
offense needs to be premised on throwing
the ball to the guy who's open and you
can't force it to one player and i feel
like last year it was a constant
narrative and this is one of the reasons
why freddie kitchens wasn't suited to be
an nfl head coach he didn't know how to
deal with that issue he got thrust into
that job that was one of the most
important things for him to handle all
year long keeping that odell beckham jr
urgency to get the football under wraps
so it doesn't disrupt your offense so it
doesn't screw up your quarterbacks
process as he goes from receiver to
receiver instead of just finding the
open man he feels like he's got to get
it to obj or obj's not going to be happy
so
can is it before we talk about
where obj could go if the browns are
indeed thinking about trading because
we're talking about this there was a
report yesterday from wfan that the
browns are talking to the vikings about
trading otto beckham jr there
how do they salvage it in cleveland how
do they turn year two into something
better than what it was in year one
well okay the first thing is hey baker
mayfield had a down year all right you
know they had some past protection
issues you talked about freddy kitchens
being new to the job i think that could
have been approached a little bit
differently as far as
things they were doing to
make odell beckham jr the focal point a
little bit
and again
you know he wasn't healthy i mean as we
know he got surgery right after the year
was over you know and again as much as
we say oh odell beckham jr we're scared
of him he might be a diva blah blah blah
blah blah he didn't ask for more money
last year he played through injury the
whole year and we didn't really hear
about it to the end of the season and
within that he still had a thousand
yards receiving so you know i don't look
at it as it went wrong i just don't
think it went to what people's
expectations are and that's where i'm
cleveland right now and i'm just going
there's just no way i wouldn't make that
trade right now i wouldn't you haven't
seen the best of this player and just
again you know mike you know i'm i'm a
fanboy here of odell beckham jr but
that's because you know when healthy
he's as talented as i've ever seen in
the history of the sport at wide
receiver route running quickness you
know straight ahead explosion and speed
the ability to make people miss i mean
there's really no weakness to his game
and like i said in the first hour mike
he had a lot of value to that offense
because of the attention
that he garnered on a week-to-week basis
so if they've decided in cleveland that
they are going to explore their options
for what they can get john dorsey's gone
freddie kitchens is gone you've got a
new regime there the only common
denominator is ownership in paul d
podesta but if they've decided that this
just isn't going to work long term
where do you think if not minnesota
where do you think potential landing
spots for odo beckham jr would be
well all right so i mean again i i will
say the raiders they have a multitude of
picks they have a desperate need at the
position
i don't really envision that happening
but i know that john gruden would
certainly fancy a guy like odell beckham
jr just like he did antonio brown you
know these are special special talents
but i think they have more
holes to fill on their roster probably
right now that's not realistic now the
other two teams i'm gonna go to one we
heard in the trade conversation a lot
for a wide receiver the new england
patriots were involved in the deandre
hopkins conversation and the stephon dix
conversation and i think if you tell
bill belichick it's only gonna take a
second and a five and a fifth to get
odell beckham jr i think they would be
very real players and i'll please raise
my hand for green bay packers to get in
that conversation as well you know why
man
aaron rodgers and odell beckham jr i
think that's a marriage that could last
a long long time and really be
successful they fit as far as their
style of plays together in a lot of ways
too so i those are three teams that jump
out to me the latter two more than the
raiders
to me the thing that told me that odell
beckham jr was not long for cleveland
with the comments he made before they
played the patriots last year it's
obvious he craves that kind of structure
he craves that kind of organization
which is which is stunning because he
seems like the last guy who would sign
on for the patriot way where you check
your ego and your individuality at the
door but he seems to want that because
he understands that's a path to winning
championships and building your legacy
so i feel like he is despite his talents
beyond his years i feel like he's still
kind of young naive immature and he
wants someone
to say
this is how we win football games this
is how we build the right kind of
program this is how we pursue
championships that's what he clearly
wants every outburst we've ever seen
from him comes from a desire to win
yes i think he does want to play for the
patriots now the patriots without tom
brady
right that may be a different issue and
the problem is the buccaneers don't need
otto beckham jr they have a full house
at receiver so no doubt i you know the
patriots not as as clear as they would
have been a year ago or if brady had
stayed so i re you know the 49ers were a
team that was pursuing him last year and
some think the giants actually took less
from the browns than what they could
have gotten from the 49ers to get obj
out of the division do you think san
francisco should jump back into this
well
you know they have the assets to do it
with the 13th and 31 pick in the first
round
you know i i do think there's some
possibility there for that conversation
yeah i don't think that's totally crazy
i don't and again you know yeah my buddy
kyle shanahan he's got an eye for town
he sees the game through the wide
receiver's eyes that's why guys like
julio jones and andre johnson and even
pierre garcon with the washington
redskins thrived with shanahan and we
saw deebo samuel last year so i think
that's in the possibility yes you know
again a little bit it's going to be
dictating how teams want to fill their
roster through the draft and you know
mike with odell beckham jr i think you
make a great point i mean first off i
think this guy wants to be great i know
that and anytime we see him doing a
video he's working out he's trying to
get better that's all he does you know
he's obsessed with it i think he does
want an organization that meets the
standard he sees and you know to your
point with where you know again
you know you know okay yes he's been a
little bit of a pain in the butt here
and there you know i'll take my
experience with randy moss a little bit
you know randy moss what i learned more
than anything is when he got unhappy or
disgruntled you know and even there are
conversations i had with him were more
times because he felt like the
organization wasn't meeting the standard
i think you never heard a peep from him
in new england one because of the
culture but two i think he saw and went
man they do everything perfect and they
work all day and they're obsessive and
they always have creative ideas
and this is unbelievable i got nothing
to be unhappy about i just if i don't go
out and play i just got to blame myself
where i think he went to other places
and saw and went like what the hell are
these people doing here like this is
crazy and then he gets frustrated and
then he spouts off and i think that
could be the same for a guy like odell
beckham jr as well
are you smirking about that
i'm just i'm
just the whole thing just it's it's
amazing to me that this has become a
story a week before the draft but i'm
telling you
my my spider sense is tingling on this
one i feel like i hear anything to it
the way the report came out i think the
vikings were doing their homework talked
to someone with the giants and someone
from the giants told someone from
wfan and that's how it all got out there
and i think it's something that the
browns are exploring and the failure of
the browns to shout from the rooftops
that we are not trading odo beckham jr
to me is the best evidence that they're
at least keeping their options open
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports